the superhero genre has seen its fair
share of Tinseltown a listers come and
go here's why some of the biggest names
abandoned their most super heroic roles
heads up some spoilers ahead over the
years Hugh Jackman has appeared as the
internally conflicted Wolverine a
whopping nine times but his ownership of
the role was clear the first time he
donned the claws for x-men at this point
it's almost impossible to imagine
another actor in the role but unless
there's a dramatic turn of events it
seems that's just what we'll have to do
prior to suiting up for Logan Jackman
announced that his ninth appearance as
Wolverine would ultimately be his last
according to People magazine believe it
or not a chat with Jerry Seinfeld about
his decision to finally leave Seinfeld
had a hand in Jackman's decision to walk
away from the character here he said
look when you're creating something it's
very important not to run yourself dry
it's not about finishing on top
necessarily but making sure that you're
creatively still got something left
Jackman says he decided that same day to
make Logan his final film as Wolverine
luckily he left with a bang the film was
a massive critical and box office
success and serves as a fitting final
chapter Christopher Nolan's The Dark
Knight made Christian Bale the
definitive Batman for many fans of the
character after Nolan walked away Warner
Brothers was desperate to keep Vale on
board according to Business Insider
prior to announcing Batman vs Superman
dawn of Justice Warner Brothers
reportedly offered bail as much as 50
million dollars to Don the Cape for
director Zack Snyder but Bale it seems
had seen enough of life in the Batcave
because he turned down the loot and
retired his bat suit for good
Nolan choosing not to return to the
franchise was a big part of his decision
according to screen crush Bale has
always maintained that he and Nolan
already told the Batman story they
wanted to tell but he also said he
wouldn't say no if Nolan came to him
with a new Batman script Michael Keaton
also turned down a stack of Benjamin's
and walked away from playing Batman in
Batman Forever back in 1995 that move
came a full 6 years after he first
donned the cape for Tim Burton in the
Venge onra defining film Batman the film
proved a massive
with fans and a financial juggernaut at
the box office as did the pair's
deliciously divisive follow-up Batman
Returns though Keaton didn't immediately
exit Batman forever
he certainly began to rethink his
involvement once Burton wasn't on board
apparently he knew he was done after he
read the rewritten script in Keaton's
own words yeah there you go Keaton felt
so passionately that he reportedly
turned down a fifteen million dollar
payday to reprise the role it's been a
bumpy road to respectability for
Marvel's tortured bad-boy vigilante
Frank Castle that road took an
interesting turn in 2004 when a
big-screen version of The Punisher got
the green light
sadly the excitement faded fast once the
film was released to put it mildly the
film with a critical and commercial
failure
but Thomas Jane's ability to bring the
right mix of malice and melodrama was
enough for the studio to sign him up for
the planned sequel Punisher war zone but
according to antique cool news Jane left
the project just prior to cameras
rolling because he felt the sequel
script was quote too comic book and
didn't give Frank Castle the treatment
he deserved if you're wondering what
happened to that film it was released in
2008 and met with just as much critical
and commercial strife as the original
history it seems as proven Thomas Jane
right Hugh Jackman isn't the only member
of the Logan cast that decided to ride
off into the sunset after Wolverines
last stand Patrick Stewart Professor X
himself also announced his departure
from the x-men universe prior to Logan's
release according to Entertainment
Weekly if you've seen Logan already the
news that Stewart is out will come as no
surprise since the character meets his
own end in the film of course death
hasn't stopped Professor X from
returning to the franchise before still
like Logan's slow somber goodbye most
fans believe X's ultimate fate was just
as perfect for his part Stewart
seems to agree check out one of our
newest videos right here
plus even more looper videos about your
favorite stuff for coming soon subscribe
to our YouTube channel and hit the bell
so you don't miss a single one
you
[Music]